thomas l
friedman has been the new york times
foreign affairs columnist for decades
and that can make a fella
a little lazy and over-reliant on what
his driver from the airport to the
downtown hotel has to say about the
scene in
bangalore or wagga dugou or wherever
he's ludicrously fond
of fitting every single global
development into the same old
clapped-out analogy
friedman 2008 in jfk's waiting lounge we
could barely find a place to sit
18 hours later we landed at singapore's
ultra-modern airport with free
internet portals and children's play
zones we felt like we had just flown
from the flintstones to the jetsons
friedman 2007
fly from zurich's ultra modern airport
to laguardia's dump
it's like flying from the jetsons to the
flintstones
friedmann 2002 for all the talk about
the vaunted
afghan fighters this was a war between
the jetsons and the flintstones
and the jetsons one and the flintstones
know it
uh but they didn't did they so the most
technologically advanced military on the
planet
has spent two decades having a
yabba-dabba-doo time up against goat
herds with
fertilizer so here's friedman with fredo
on cnn the other night doing what sounds
like his usual
rhapsodizing about jetson countries over
flintstone america
the high-speed bullet he refers to is a
train not what the tricoms
pump into the poor old uyghurs at their
concentration camps
but listen to what he says next
do you know that it takes four hours and
18 minutes to take the bullet train
from beijing to shanghai and it takes 21
hours
to take the train from new york to
chicago i'll tell you something they
weren't thinking about in china this
week
they weren't thinking about some
knucklehead they weren't spending the
week thinking about a knucklehead who
claimed 911 didn't happen
they weren't thinking about some guy
who's a q anon shaman
i don't know they were probably thinking
about some bad stuff with the uyghurs
and all of that oh
for sure but i guarantee you they
weren't wasting their time
on this nonsense bad stuff with the
uyghurs like
uh harvesting their body parts yeah well
thomas friedman's always been a little
turned on by the chinese polar bureau
a while back he wished we could be quote
china for a day
so we could enact enlightened policies
like
banning plastic grocery bags without
having to have pelosi and mcconnell
negotiated back and forth for a year
and a half before sneaking it into a
footnote of a five thousand page bill on
transgender bathroom access quote one
party
autocracy certainly has its drawbacks
but when it is led by a reasonably
enlightened group of people as
china is today it can have great
advantages
unquote just so we know where he's going
with this
but he has a kind of a point here in no
serious world
is q anon or a minor freshman
representative's views on
jewish space lasers causing forest fires
a dominant news story
and when you're talking about that
you're not talking about anything
important
china is a dictatorship in thomas
friedman terms it's a hybrid
a cruel crude hard power thug state
with state-of-the-art technology half
flintstone
half jetson meet the jetstones
but it thinks like a conventional great
power focused
on how to advance its national interests
and how do we do this week after week
month after month and think we are a
serious country
we are so deeply unserious as a country
right now and we need to put this
crap behind us okay and get focused on
the future
fair enough but how far is he prepared
to go when you're talking about marjorie
taylor green you're not serious when
you're talking about q anon you're not
serious
when you're talking about renaming the
washington redskins or uncle ben's rice
you're not serious
when you're talking about what pronouns
to use you're not serious when you're
talking about the paris climate accords
as if it's going to do a single thing
for the climate
you're not serious when you're using the
floor of your national legislature
for a self-help therapy session you're
not serious
when you're saying diversity is our
strength
as opposed to a morally neutral abstract
noun you're not serious
china is a conventional non-diverse
great power
that doesn't waste a moment talking
about social justice
or confederate statues or non-binary
pronouns
and you'd be surprised how much time
that frees up for taking over the planet
ah but don't worry thomas friedman knows
a serious guy when he sees one
and that's why i am praying for joe
biden because i think he's a serious guy
he's trying to do the right thing and i
think he is cursed by a republican party
that is chasing a man encourage people
to sack our capital you have to stop and
repeat that
they sacked our capital
oh total blithering god swallow have you
ever seen a sac
capital and he was doing so well we're
unserious we need to get
serious and then the letdown joe biden
serious that's the fundamentally
unserious
thomas l friedman uh former deputy
national security adviser under
president trump
katie mcfarland is here she's the author
of
the book revolution and katie you've
been uh
watching china a long time
is the jig up i mean have they basically
uh got everything they want right now
and
and we're reduced to a like a a great
power theme park as it were we have all
the outward
attributes of a great power but we're
not doing any great power things and the
chinese are
well the chinese aren't there yet but
they have every intention to be there
within the decade and they're doing it a
number of different ways i mean they're
doing it with technology they're doing
it with their economy
they're doing it with alliances they're
now having military exercises with the
russians
the iranians with turkey they're moving
out and i think tom friedman's right to
a certain extent
is because the americans we were totally
distracted for 20 years we were
distracted
by the middle east fighting wars we knew
we couldn't win in afghanistan and iraq
and now we're distracted again we were
distracted during the russia hoax
and now we're distracted by this
political show trial of an impeachment
so whose fault is that i don't really
think it's donald trump's fault as much
as tom friedman would like to make it so
donald trump was the only guy who
understood the threat that china posed
um unlike joe biden who says hey come on
guys they're
really good mark you know they want to
eat our breakfast lunch and dinner and
they expect us to pay for it
absolutely and you you mentioned these
naval exercises
uh that they're doing with the russians
and the iranians and we
sort of think that all these guys okay
they may all be opposed
to us but they don't get along
particularly well
with each other and it looks as if they
do
i mean they're doing these things in the
indian ocean which with well within
living memory
used to be a british lake now the
chinese control all those
ports in burma bangladesh uh and sri
lanka
i mean they're on the rise pretty fast
and they're they know exactly what
they're doing and they have a strategic
plan i mean when you say well they don't
like each other the russians don't like
the chinese don't like
who cares they're doing business with
each other and what we did in the united
states during the whole russia hoax is
we push
russia into the arms of china and now
look what's happening even in the last
couple of days the
germans have said well we don't want to
take sides between
china and the united states and they've
also said russia
go ahead and build a pipeline we want
russian gas well
you know where's the united states and
all this we just bring out the checkbook
and we keep
making the same mistakes again when joe
biden says oh america's back
really back to that good old days where
we were pushed around by everybody and
we paid for everything
you know it's not just the uh the
russians and the iranians though the
chinese have done naval exercises
with the royal australian navy are you
worried that uh america's allies
are actually figuring who's the coming
who's the coming man in this scenario
well that's the worry is that they have
our allies in the in the pacific or even
in europe they
look around and they say well i guess we
don't really like this
but we better cut our deal i mean i
think the united states is in a position
if we choose to do it if we summon the
national will
where we can regain the commanding
heights of technology and we can cut the
commanding heights of our relationships
but that doesn't mean you know you need
to have some leverage
and the administration talks a really
good game i mean it's great words
but where are the deeds i mean are they
willing to use the leverage we have
so far they have not so far they've
talked but they haven't done and i think
that's what worries me is four more
four years of this and then the united
states will be in a very difficult
position
and far more difficult if ever to get
back to where we need to be
that doesn't matter thinking about katie
great analysis
as always terrific to see you tonight uh
coming up